comment décririez-vous ce qu'est le cercle
pour payer votre grand-mère le chaos du
web a fait repousser l'élégance Paul ou
John début Paul fin John gloire ou sorte
de voir sonique fin Mario les besoins de la
société ou les besoins de l'individu
devraient être les mêmes ils '  j'ai le plus peur
de je suis trop potentiel de terrain je
crois en la perfectibilité de l'être humain
nous sommes notre meilleur moi les possibilités
sont infinies
après le cercle il y a un problème que nous
ne pouvons pas résoudre nous pouvons guérir n'importe quelle maladie et
nous pouvons et avons faim sans  secrètement
sans les informations sur l'audiologie que nous pouvons
enfin réaliser ou les circulaires de pétition que vous aimez
partager
nous sommes en direct mais il y a des problèmes alors que nous nous
cachons, nous nous soucions de tout le monde au Kerala
parce que savoir c'est bien mais savoir
tout ce qui est mieux pour
vous
[Musique]